eben bei den filmfestspielen in venedig
premiere also ich hätte gern dass du
mein knie ist aus dem grund da war
verunsichert und ich möchte gern dass
durango schießt um sicher zu werden und
sicher zu schießen und das
selbstvertrauen bekommen
ulrich seidel präsentiert am
filmfestival venedig seinen neuen
dokumentarfilm safari ein film über
urlauber auf großwildjagd in afrika auch
kein militanter tierschützer aber ich
bin sicher in meiner seele ein
tierschützer also tiere sind jedenfalls
schützenswert natürlich somit seinen
begriff tausende touristen reisen jedes
jahr nach afrika auf der jagd nach
trophäen die beziehung des jägers zum
tier ist distanziert was sich in der
jägersprache niederschlägt das tier das
man schießen möchte wird stück genannt
es blut das fließt schweiß dass sich den
kreislauf gepumpt haben alle spuren des
todes werden rein gewaschen und damit
auch die blutigen hände des jägers auf
der erinnerungsfoto muss alles perfekt
sein
die großwildjagd ist eine
weitverbreitete freizeitbeschäftigung
könig juan carlos auf elefanten jagd
die trump söhne mit einem getöteten
leopard
aktuell macht die zwölfjährige ariana
goldin schlagzeilen auf facebook
posierte junge jägerin aus den usa mit
getöteten wildtieren
zuletzt löste sie ende august einen
shitstorm aus ich würde mit ihr gerne
dasselbe machen was sie den armen tieren
angetan hat sie lieben tieren
wir lieben tiere ebenfalls aber wir
lieben es auch auf die jagd zu gehen
tierschützer gehen auf die barrikaden
und protestieren gegen die großwildjagd
doch die wird zum massenphänomen
schon weil sie wie seidel zeigt
inzwischen für jedermann erschwinglich
geworden ist das töten von tieren nur um
die persönliche jagd los zu befriedigen
wird von gegnern scharf verurteilt
ulrich seidel hingegen weitet den blick
sieht mehr als nur jäger in der pflicht
dann muss man aber auch die
massentierhaltung zum beispiel bieten
oder dagegen sein dann muss man auch die
ganze industrielle fleisch verarbeitung
und die haltung und schlachtung da muss
man genauso dagegen sein und das ist das
problem ein bisschen dass das ist ja
tabuisierten in unseren gesellschaften
weil damit hat jeder ein bisschen zu tun
die müssten dann selber sozusagen die
verantwortung übernehmen was seidel mit
seinem schockierenden dokumentarfilm
einmal mehr zeigt der mensch nimmt sich
was er will und wann bs wenn die frage
ist nur wie lange noch